the best single thing you could have
done on march 11
1942 when i bought my first stock was
just buy an index fund
and and and never look at a headline a
stock that doesn't pay a dividend is a
speculation
it's not an investment i try to create
things that last and if you want to make
money while you sleep
having that kind of focus something that
is still relevant and valuable in 5
10 20 years is super helpful want to be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the secrets
to passive income enjoy
okay let's kick it off with secret
number one use good debt with robert
kiyosaki
income expense
asset liability so debt falls in here
so if you let's say i'm going to buy and
everybody says i'm going to buy a house
ever since my house is an asset that's
not true
your house is a liability i don't care
if you have no debt on it or not a house
is a liability same as if you have
a car
a car is a liability and the reason for
that is as we talked about earlier the
six
words that are basics of financial
education financial intelligence
income expense asset liability and the
two other words are cash flow
so when you look at the average person
they have a job
money comes in here they pay for their
house
and the money goes to a bank
through a mortgage so it's not an
asset because the cash is flying flowing
out so it's a liability
so the definition of liability does it
take money from your pocket and for an
asset does it put money in your pocket
so when i have a rental property here
it puts money in my pocket so if i live
in a house it's a liability
because even i have no debt on it i
still have taxes depreciation repairs
and upkeep
insurance and all this when i rent a
property i've done a good job buying it
and structuring it
every month it sends me money so i
started off when i was 25
i had a little one-bedroom condo
and it put 25 bucks in my pocket
it was a start so this was good debt
you say this the debt also went out and
paid
but it also put 25 in my pocket
so net net i was making money from my
little house so today my wife and i own
six thousand
five hundred of them and every month six
thousand
five hundred houses put money in my
pocket my
my people who live in them love paying
all this because they have a place to
live
but all of this comes from debt
so we don't oh we have a hundred percent
finance here
it's all debt so this is good debt
and what makes a good debt is the two
most important words
cash flow so what most people do is they
have student loan debt
sl and that debt is going out this way
you know it doesn't put any money in
your pocket you can say well i have a
job
well there's still you working for it so
i don't work for any of this money here
i do this job once set the deal up every
year i add more and more and more
i'm borrowing money from here it's
coming here
and going this way so the debt is
putting money in my pocket
and bad debt is taking money from my
pocket
so the the problem is if you're going to
use that you've got to be much smarter
than this person here you've got to be
very very smart
that's why i took real estate classes
when i was 25
and i've never stopped taking real
estate classes because you buy a piece
of real estate and you make a mistake
this turns into a liability
this if i'm if if i get the renter
leaves the place
this goes here that fast and the cash
flows that way
okay it's going out of my pocket so it's
nothing to do with real estate it's
nothing to do with the car
that there was student loan it has to do
with these two words here
so good debt again is debt when i borrow
for this
and it puts money in my pocket if i had
a car
and i borrowed money from it and
somebody rented for me as an uber driver
for something and i put money in my
pocket
it would be an asset my wife and i have
a boat
and you know most boats lose money but
our boat makes money because it's in a
charter
you know people rent my boat all the
time
so there's nothing to do whether it's a
boat student loan debt
a house a car or whatever it has to do
with these two words here
secret number two get paid by royalties
with dan lok
pay by royalties example as an author
i've written now 13 books
there are books on amazon i have books
on on my audiobooks on audible.com
every single time someone maybe you're
my fan
of my work you go there and you buy a
book i get a little royalty
every single month from audible from
amazon
that's paid by royalties songwriters
they get paid by royalties
movie makers sometimes directors
sometimes
movie stars actor actress they get piece
of the action
they're also paid by royalties
so think about what are some of the ways
because when you are getting paid by
royalties
even though i'm making this video right
now i'm getting paid
even when i'm sleeping i'm getting paid
24 7 just like this
so pay by royalties hi this is dan lok i
want to share with you
a lesson from evan carmichael's new book
build
to serve this section is about making
money from your purpose
you have to embrace that if you never
learn how to make money from your
purpose
you always end up needing a day job and
your purpose will become
a hobby if that sounds like a great life
to you
then i'm happy for you if not then you
need to figure out a money-making model
that makes sense one that is consistent
one that is
significant one that can pay you so you
can quit your job and succeed
to the point where you are providing
jobs for others
and helping even more people you see
money is nothing more than a byproduct
of value creation the more people that
you serve
the more successful that you will be so
to have long-term success it's not just
built a lot or
or built to sell or even build a skill
it is built
to serve and this book will teach you
exactly
how to do that secret number three
invest in
index funds with warren buffett so this
time i went back
actually to 1942 when i bought my first
stock as an illustration
of all the things that have happened
since 1942 we've had
we've had 14 presidents seven
republicans
seven democrats we've had we've had
world wars we had 911 we had the cuban
missile crisis we have
all kinds of things the best single
thing you could have done
on march 11 1942 when i bought my first
stock
was just buy an index fund and and
and never look at a headline never think
about stocks anymore just like you would
do if you bought a farm you just buy the
formula
let the tenant farmer run it for you and
i pointed out that if you put
ten thousand dollars in an index fund
that reinvested
dividends and i paused for a moment to
let the audience
try and guess how much it amount to and
it would come to 51 million dollars now
and the only thing you had to really
believe in then
is that america would win the war and
that america would progress
as it has ever since 1776 and that
american business if america moved
forward american business would move
forward
you didn't have to worry about what
stock to buy you didn't have to worry
one day to get in and out you didn't
you didn't know the federal reserve
would exist whatever it might be
and uh america works secret number four
get stocks that earn dividends with
kevin o'leary
the only thing that matters is free cash
flow that's
it there is no other reason to own a
stock
and with that philosophy it brings you
into a place
where you focus on the company's ability
to generate
incremental cash flow because just
owning a dividend paying stock is not
good enough because
you know let's say we find a stock today
that's paying a three percent dividend
yield and tomorrow because
it's forecast for sales get cut in half
the stock drops by 50
now it's yielding six percent i don't
want to own that stock either
so my tests in this index that i've you
know created with ftse russell
looks at the balance sheet every year we
test
to make sure that the company is viable
in its ability to generate cash this is
extremely conservative investing this is
for the long
haul these tools are not for as you're
suggesting
for spicy you know the hot stock du jour
i've done that i've been there you know
let the young legs do that i have zero
interest in that i don't care what the
hot new stock is
you know when when a company comes
public i won't own it either it's got to
prove to me
over multiple years that it can continue
to generate cash
before it even fits into what i'm doing
so
i'm really boring and i like it that way
we're talking about
real money here the stuff that you need
to preserve
you know when i think about my family
trust i can't afford to mess around with
that
in my world you never touch your
principal you adjust
your spending habits your gifts to
charities your use of capital based
on how much you can generate from your
portfolio
i view my portfolio and my trust and my
positions
as a chicken on a spit dripping cash
everything has to generate yield whether
it's a fixed income position
or an equity it has to the only reason
it can be in my world is generating
capital back to me
i take that i disperse it the family
lives off that the charities i've
committed to
so i'm always looking for a company that
can help me with my problem
of generating more yield everything that
i mean i can't even imagine buying a
stock that doesn't pay a difference why
would you do that
what would be the reason you would do
that i don't get it so to me
that means about 28 of of the market
to me is just speculation a staff that
doesn't pay a dividend is a speculation
it's not an investment and secret number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip
is look for stability with grant cardone
passive income is the support mechanism
this is why you guys need this right
because if if you're
active working and getting money
and you don't have this dang
dang dang healthy unhealthy
hurt unheard business stops or doesn't
stop technology gets to rest
so what you need to do is you guys you
you and your wife or you and your
husband need to sit down and figure out
hey how do we get passive income how do
we do that you could go buy a t and t
stock if you bought a t and t stock
symbol is t
10 years ago it was 40 i think it was 42
dollars a share
okay today it's 34 a share you would
have lost
eight dollars but here's what you would
have earned you would
you would have earned a six percent
dividend
let's say you put ten thousand dollars
in it
this is passive income you took the
money from the active income
after taxes you invested 10 grand you
bought
at t stock in 2007
2008 2009 world came to an end
the stock went from 42 to 34
i think it's 34 bucks today
but you were paid a six percent dividend
okay
six percent on ten thousand dollars is
six hundred dollars for ten years
you were paid 600 every quarter
march june i think september
and december you get a check for 150
bucks
every quarter every three months they
send you what's called a dividend
this is passive income you guys with me
six percent on the 10
000 is 600 bucks a year so watch even
though the stock went down
okay 10 years let's say this is 10 years
this is 42 or 45 and now it went down to
33 or 34 whatever the number is
somewhere near
even though the stock went down watch
what happened the dividend the passive
portion of the
investment paid you back
six thousand dollars out of your 10 000.
now if you sell it today you're going to
be selling it for a third less than you
paid for it
seven grand but you were paid back six
grand
so you still made money right now the
the fact is you don't really care about
the loss
listen to what i'm saying right here you
pay ten thousand it's only worth seven
grand today
you really don't care about the loss
because you made the loss when you
bought it
the loss incurred when you bought it
what do i mean by that you took six
seven ten thousand dollars
and you gave it to an institution it
bought a piece of paper
no more valuable than this piece of
paper by the way the piece of paper was
locked away in fact it's so valueless to
you
you you can't even find that piece of
paper it's literally one little piece of
paper that says you own ten thousand
dollars for the at t stock
cross your fingers and hope pray to god
that it's gonna be all right every
quarter
every three months you gotta check they
sent you a little check 150 bucks 150
bucks 150 bucks
that little check over 10 years paid you
back 6 000
okay you lost your money when you bought
the check when you bought the paper
when you bought the at t stock what do i
mean you lost the money you lost it
because you gave them money
for this piece of paper right
what you want to do right here is you
want to stop buying things that go down
or up
you want to start buying things that
stay stable and pay you a big dividend
with the hope of a big bang
what you need to do is this okay if i'm
making 100 grand a year
oops if i make and let's take a caller
if i make a hundred thousand dollars a
year
what your goal should be is hey i need
to match that with a hundred thousand
dollars worth of passive income
i want them both ultimately what i want
is more passive income than
active income okay i'm just going to
tell you guys a little sneaky story
this year i will probably make this much
money
a month off passive income
the lowest taxed income i worked the
least for it okay it continues on after
i die
nothing can stop it okay and i'm not
having a push and pound right
nothing can stop this so the the key
ingredients to to
passive income one you want to match
your at your active and number two you
want to invest in things that will not
not go down in value number two they
don't go down in value they stay
that means you need real things not
pieces of paper you don't want a piece
of paper you want a real asset
second qualifier the third qualifier
they should never be disrupted
only invest in companies that cannot be
disrupted
why did at t stock go from 45 to 32
because it's in telecom and it's being
disrupted you understand
facebook will be disrupted trust me
youtube will be disrupted google will be
disrupted over time apple will be
disrupted
there will be a time when we don't have
this phone all you got to do is go back
and watch
movies and tv shows that were made in
the 50s 60s and 70s
look at all the things in the scenes
that aren't around anymore okay
that telephone that your mama used to do
the rotary it won't be around anymore
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35 is
not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following through jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps in 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen so
question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to celebrate alongside with
you
if you look at the videos that i make
most of them
are evergreen it's called evergreen
content because whether you watch it
today or whether you watch it in five
years
the content is still relevant and
valuable i love creating things
that are of timeless value because it's
valuable to somebody today and it's also
valuable somebody next year and in five
years and in 10 years and 20 years
you know when we're showing clips of
martin luther king or napoleon hill
the video footage may be decades old but
it's still relevant and helpful and
valuable to
me and to you today and so how that
helps you make money while you sleep is
you spend a lot of time making something
and it
sucks when it only lasts for a day or a
week or a month
and then it shoots to zero so if you're
doing something around the trend if
you're covering
the election right now it might be
really hot right now because everybody's
talking about it
but nobody's going to care once the
election is over nobody's going to look
back
on a lot of the content that was created
and i hate that kind of business because
i want to make something
and have it live forever and i want
people to pay attention to it
forever and so all the work that i do
every new
thing that i add into my business adds
multiple streams for me down the future
and so it continues to build and build
and build and build
and so i try to create things that last
and if you want to make money while you
sleep
having that kind of focus something that
is still relevant and valuable in 5
10 20 years is super helpful to you
making money while you sleep what do you
think most entrepreneurs do wrong
most entrepreneurs they make money and
they don't reinvest it
you know they blow it and then you know
economy is cyclical
when the business has a you know dip
and they've bought all these ferraris
cars lamborghinis
and they didn't reinvest and they'll
you know had a bad spot in financial
spot so financially you weren't cashing
out you know when you started and we'll
get into when you started making
good money in real estate but you didn't
start cashing out and buying luxury
stuff right away right or no did you
kind of were you patient with it or what
was your process
yeah my process was with my investment
was always reinvest the money
it's like you know buying a cow you
don't sell the cow you sell the milk and
even when you sell the milk you take
part of the profit
and invested in a second cow yeah you
know
and only with that 30 of it whatever it
may be
you go by you know ipad iphone whatever
you have so my mentality was always
reinvest reinvest reinvest
you know don't spend the principal
reinvest the cash flow
you know and that's how i've amassed all
this real estate
and i told myself i said hey i'm going
to buy a bugatti when i can buy 10 of
them cash
you know but most entrepreneurs they go
ahead and
finance it and they start taking a lot
of a lot of loans
in and then when the business slows down
it's you know overwhelming
and you know they start having financial
difficulty and
some of them don't survive you know but
to me is whatever your trade is make the
money
invest in real estate and be patient
and every time recession comes keep
buying the thing about garage sale
that really turns me on is the thrill of
the hunt because it's
the place where you can really score a
huge box of toys for three bucks
worth three hundred how many yeah i'm
gonna carry on you
uh you're like four hundred don't need
that much
15 bucks 30 bucks like i don't know
usually
usually truly you only need about 100
bucks this could be decent
looks a little too new but we're about
to
strike they're striking to be done here
how much of the stuffed animals
50 cents good
spongebob baby
how much is this
all right stuffed animals continue to be
my score 50 cents a pop dumbo disney
store snuffle up i guess
bang olaf what and this one's going to
be a beast
the fao schwartz fao schwartz giraffe
so we just looked it up the uh the
jeffrey uh
giraffe toys r us fao shorts combo 30
bucks
paid 50 cents i don't know what else to
say after ebay fees just like a quick 20
bucks
just a lot of people not making 20 bucks
an hour
not just one of the things wait till i
look up the snuffle up with this
thank you so much you gotta look this is
pretty exciting to me vintage lego thing
never opened
uh about 2003 jesus i'm getting old but
still 15 years old i'm excited to
open this up this was a huge score
already looked it up
paid three they wanted five paid three
uh for these spider-man skates in
package never opened as well
or opened um pretty excited about it
oh don't worry
[Music]
that's so awesome i heard all right
let's go
yeah she goes at least go around the
corner don't kill me
so good so good lego four
zero nine eight twenty five bucks give
it to me
all right pay two bucks for this all
right cool
so some ac snow globes in there
and they are better than i think i
thought
you're gonna go back and buy it yep
would you do ten if i bought three yeah
okay you have a bag
i do have a bag awesome this is exciting
we just bought three snow globes for 10
bucks
and i'm fired up i'm fired up my guy
i'm fired up all right how do you feel
feeling really good now
it's starting to get hot getting some
stuff now
well over the 200 range maybe a little
bit more even
i feel much better
a whole lot when you need it and like
it's probably more we'll see
what it says too would you take a dollar
for this sure thanks
all right picked up the scary bear for a
dollar
called for real from tiger 2004 let's
see what it's worth
20 bucks all day all day 20 bucks
who me because i get more excited about
this than like
getting an angle oh i get better
just picked up two jerseys for two bucks
a piece kevin durant
seattle supersonics jersey pretty rare
two bucks
garnett really nice one actually
stitched celtics
two bucks each we'll see 64 bucks for
the
durant i mean
you know pay two bucks you saw my
there's a little bit of like shitty
stains on it i can clean that off
just crazy if i was really doing this
i'd make a thousand a week easy
and if you like on just saturday
just working saturday night so ugh
i mean i genuinely think
goodwill ebay buying bulk on ebay
selling in ams like
i just think this is the hundred
thousand dollar a year thing for so many
people making
30 to 60 000 a year i feel phenomenal
this is the big final score it's about
100 bucks minimum
and now i know about cherish teddies now
i'm a cherished teddy's player
and every time you become more of a
player of a new thing look this is very
simple
spent 40 50 20 40 bucks 50 bucks
easily now into the five or six hundred
dollar range of resale
i just wish so many of you would do this
it's four five six hundred bucks
every weekend it's now 11 47
so we're four hours in a little gas
money
i get it but like net net two three four
hundred bucks
every weekend and if you don't want to
be like tedious because now you gotta
post in all this
cool just throw up this huge collection
of cherished teddy's 80 bucks boom quick
little you know 60 bucks here
it adds up when you got groceries when
you got bills when you got college
loans when you got rent people sitting
around dwelling
85 90 of this country working you know
minimum wages low incomes
it just matters teaching people how to
fish flip life it's real
[Music]
if you want to learn seven natural ways
to make more money check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there so in general i try to actually
stay away from these kinds of topics
because i think a lot of people who are
interested in these things
are kind of lazy are looking for quick
ways to be able to make
make more money and they end up